écoutez bonjour à toutes et à tous ici
ragots rock et j'espère que vous avez
bien se retrouvent pour une toute
nouvelle vidéo
cependant comme vous avez pu le voir
cette vidéo est très spécial et c'est
même certainement la vidéo la plus
chanceuse
on va dire de toute ma chaîne est
certainement de toute ma vie
enfin après j'en sais rien car laissez
moi vous raconter l'histoire comme
certains ont pu le voir sur twitter il y
à de nombreux concours pour gagner la
nintendo switch qui vient à peine de
sortir et du coup moi utilisateurs de
twitter j'ai vu ces concours et je me
suis dit oh ravasi verte et retweeter
tout ça au cas où mais en même temps
j'en sais rien vous devez connaître ça
souvent des grosses enseignes organise
des concours en échange d'un retour 8 et
d'infos l'eau ce qui est une très bonne
stratégie marketing qui permet d'avoir
beaucoup plus de visibilité et de
partage et du coup carrefour france a
organisé un concours pour gagner la
nintendo switch avec le jeu 1-2 switch
et le nouveau zelda
j'ai donc re tweeté est folle au
carrefour france et là j'avais une
chance sur huit mille neuf cent et j'ai
gagné le concours pour avoir la nintendo
switch qui est ici là sous vos yeux
j'ai juste ouvert le carton juste
enlever ce coach pour pouvoir ouvrir le
carton rapidement et je suis
je sais même plus quoi dire j'ai le
coeur qui va à 100 à l'heure parce que
j'ai une chance monstrueuse et je suis
tout à fait ravi quoi donc je vous
propose de dévoiler cette swift ensemble
et on va commencer dès maintenant
déjà le petit carton pour prouver vous
devez vous allez le voir à l'envers ou à
cause d'un versement de rêver rami a
marqué hugo j'ai une chance monstrueuse
vous imaginez pas comment je suis je
suis choqué je suis encore choqué voilà
comme maître gims je suis encore choqué
mais ceux ci on va déballer ses
ensembles
attention ça me fait tout bizarre parce
qu'en plus je suis assez cartésien et du
coup j'ai participé au concours on m'a
dit que j'allais gagner mais tant que je
n'avais pas la switch bas devant moi je
n'y croyais pas vraiment quoi alors
voici les deux jeux donc voilà sans
déconner les mecs je suis choqué qu'un
de switch et vous avez les jeunes of
zelda breath of the world
c'est tout simplement incroyable
je suis vraiment choqué [ __ ] mais la
nintendo souich juste en plus ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que je suis étudiant
n'est pas les moyens pas du tout je
gagne très peu j'ai très peu d'argent du
coup je n'ai pas les moyens d'acheter la
switch du coup je pensais peut-être voir
si j'économise et bien pour décembre
pour noël quoi mais du coup c'est une
chance inespérée c'est une chance
incroyable que j'ai eu et je remercierai
jamais assez carrefour france nintendo
quoi donc franchement bas merci on va
déballer tout ça ensemble ça intéresse
le chat mais bon je vais pas la laisser
aller sur la terre parce qu'elle va
faire des conneries
[Musique]
voici les fameux joe icône concept très
particulier très design c'est très très
design c'est très pratique c'est très
fonctionnel et je suis impatient de
tester ça donc on va voir ça les touches
sont très petit ça fait bizarre
si vous le voyez bien veillé tout sont
très petites et du coup bien évidemment
l'écran complémentaires plus tôt
j'ai principal mais quelques couacs ou
lycées les deux tonnes
ici c'est plutôt assez lourd je pensais
pas on sait que si on était plus léger
que ça je t'aime elle arrête de faire
des conneries
elle arrête pas l air et c'est quelque
chose de très intéressant et très design
aussi la manette switch version ps4 ps4
xbox plutôt oui ou contrôleur wii aux
pros contrôleur tout à fait design aussi
car il suffit juste de coulisses et ça
doit être une simplicité énorme on va
falloir que je teste ça franchement
c'est très c'est très très bien pensé je
pense que nintendo là ils ont vraiment
cartonné et voici le plus intrigant
voilà c'est la console switch en fait la
console switch
c'est l'écran qu'on peut coulisser ici
du coup et qui permet ensuite de pouvoir
jouer sur la télé via un câble
certainement et je suis assez c'est
assez impressionné la vache donc c'est
un peu une console portable c'est me
console portable c'est plus console
portable quand même que console de salon
de l'avouer parce que la console c'est
simple la console c'est ça et ceci sert
à retranscrire sur la télé donc la
switch est vraiment une console de la
vie en france voilà tellement émue suis
tellement heureux d'avoir entre les
mains un essai c'est une chance inouïe
djellal c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable voici par rapport au gamepad
c'est la même taille d'écran environ
voilà un senior c'est la même taille
d'écran environ même un peu plus grand
l'écran est un peu même pas même pas non
j'ai pas l'impression que ça soit la
même danse est le plus grand non non
c'est la même taille que saluer
en gros ça va faire de la taille d'un
grain pendant
les jackson voici jeu zelda avec la
cartouche qui est vraiment tout petit
vraiment tout petit alors je voulais
tester un truc c'était de sentir parce
que apparemment nintendo romy quelque
chose pour éviter que les enfants navale
les cartouches parce qu'elles sont
vraiment très petit
je vous montre la différence avec un jeu
nintendo 3ds c'est quand même vraiment
très très petit vrai c'est la moitié
d'une cartouche en fait c'est ça la
beauté d'une cartouche ou les deux tiers
des deux tiers de la cartouche ce qui
est vraiment très très petit ensuite
voilà pour comparer par rapport à un jeu
wii lyon donc la boîte est nettement
plus petit est nettement moins larges la
moitié ce que je trouve vraiment très
intéressant et très design
parce que ça fait beaucoup plus épuré
beaucoup plus simple et c'est ce que
c'est ce que les gens aiment en fait
donc c'est la modernité tout ça je
travaille je fais mes études dans dans
le design et le développement du coup je
connais un petit peu les stratégies
commerciales pour que ça soit moderne et
que ça plaise aux gens et j'ai
franchement dit tester un peu où la
[ __ ] j'ai déjà fait faire une clonage
j'ai tellement tout tremblant s'est
testé les deuils comme les boutons sont
très petit ça fait assez bizarre mais
j'ai envie de tester par rapport à la
manette à là où notre page touche
l'écran la [ __ ] je touche déjà l'écran
j'ai assez stressé on pas se cacher
alors j'ai envie de voir si c'est
vraiment facile à glisser la vache
c'est d'une simplicité ouf oh la vache
[Musique]
et un petit en gros ça bloque à la fin
pour pouvoir cliquer s'est passé ouf
et du coup on joue comme ça les boutons
ou plutôt agréable la prise en main est
plutôt agréable
ça fait bizarre par contre que ça soit
large c'est pas dérangeante je vais vous
montrer par rapport à une nintendo ds si
vous voulez mais voilà quand je crois
nintendo ds et quand je prends la switch
de morlaix souich c'est pas la même
distance
c'est en gros deux fois l'écran l'écran
du haut ces deux fois l'écran du nom
même passé une fois j'ai vraiment
remercier carrefour france car c'est une
chance vraiment énorme
après je peux je les remercie pour
d'avoir fait le concours d'avoir
organisé le concours parce que gagner
c'est seulement ma propre chance c'est
la première fois que je gagne un
concours aussi énorme comme ça c'est
vraiment une chance inouïe que j'ai
surtout que je n'ai pas les moyens
d'acheter la switch et je veux bien en
profiter et puis n'hésitez pas à me dire
si vous aimeriez des vidéos sur la
switch et notamment sur ce jeu si zelda
si vous souhaitez des vidéos sur zelda
n'hésitez pas à lâcher un gros pouce
bleus et puis elle me le signaler dans
les commentaires je pense pas qu'un ex
play serait le bienvenu ça ne vous
intéresserait pas il y en a déjà des
centaines en à peine deux jours mais si
vous souhaitez avoir quelques vidéos sur
le jeu en très haute qualité et avoir
mon avis car zelda c'est un jeu que j'ai
énormément joué et bien n'hésitez pas à
me dire
en tout cas je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous remercie de
me suivre je suis honoré de recevoir
cette switch et je compte bien en
profiter
et dès que je pourrai on fera des lives
dessus et si vous le souhaitez des
vidéos en tout cas on va s'arrêter ici
pour cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous
aurez plus les amis je vous fais des
gros bisous je vous aime très fort
c'était tard groc que le 'lion' earth
[Musique]